law enforcement first responders we all
know that the safest thing to do is to
stay home and that is what we're asking
folks to do right now we're at a moment
of life safety and what we need the
community to do is to stay where they
are if you're at school say at school of
you're at home stay at home if you're at
work stay at work I know that a lot of
families have their kids at school we
have been in touch with the school
districts and that's the safest place
for them to be please don't try to go
outside and pick up your child they're
safer at school if you're driving to try
and get out of the vehicle and try and
make it to to a place where you can
shelter if you feel that your life is in
danger call 9-1-1 but of course folks
are safer in their homes than being
evacuated don't panic
stay in touch with the news stay alert
and we'll be posting all the information
- ready harris Dorji we are working with
an incredible group of professionals
ready to respond so let me pass it on to
Jeff Linder to talk about the weather
and then I'll share a little bit more
about what we're doing in Harris County
and how else folks can help us Jeff all
right thank you judge
we do have a flash flood emergency in
effect right now for east central Harris
County this is a life-threatening
situation we are asking people to
shelter in place do not travel I will
repeat what the judge said if you are in
a vehicle and you get encounter high
water you must get out of that vehicle
as quickly as you possibly can at this
point we're recommending do not go into
any underpasses or any low water areas
all of those right now are extremely
dangerous we are seeing rainfall rates
of four to six inches per hour across
the central portions of Harris County
we've had a rainfall rate in the greens
Point area of six and a half inches in
one hour we know we are getting
structure flooding from the roadway
street systems being completely
overwhelmed and we now have some of our
watersheds that we are watching also the
West Fork of the San Jacinto River is
rising very rapidly this is at u.s. 59
we do expect major flooding on the West
work of the San Jacinto River so this is
the Bella woods area those areas east of
us 59 we also expect major flooding on
the East Fork of the San Jacinto River
this is from over 20 inches of rain that
has fallen in that area over the last
day and a half the Bayou situation we
have overbank conditions on Cedar Bayou
that is in the eastern part of Harris
County along the Liberty County line
from the headwaters or where the Bayou
starts around FM 1960 down to us highway
90 and we expect flooding all the way
down to FM 1942 this evening I 10 and
possibly into the bay town city limits
highway 146 later this evening and
tonight hauls Bayou has risen very
rapidly the Bayou at airline and I 45
near Mount Houston was rising at a rate
of a half a foot every two minutes it is
exceeding its bank structure flooding is
likely in that location from that
portion of the Bayou all the way down to
u.s. highway 59
greens Bayou is also going over banks
near us 59 we're also getting very high
in the greens Point area so some of the
locations that we have historically had
flooding in the greens Point area we are
monitoring that and there could be some
water going into structures in that area
and then lastly gardeners Bayou this is
on the northeast side of Harris County
near Intercontinental Airport and the
humble area it is over banks near the
northeast side of beltway 8 that's
probably more just the rural areas
there's not a lot of structures right
next to the Bayou there a couple of
other points a couple of other
situations we're watching very closely
Brickhouse gulley white oak by you lower
Buffalo Bayou that's Buffalo Bayou east
of the Beltway and then getting down
into the southern part of the county
with this heavy rain is moving right now
braised Bayou from about the Meijer land
area east now those channels are okay at
the moment but they are rising very
quickly with this type of rainfall and
we're going to have to watch those very
carefully
eventually this rain is going to get
down onto the Clear Creek area that was
hit so hard the other night their ground
is very saturated that Creek is still
elevated I suspect we will have issues
on Clear Creek Turkey Creek and Beemer
ditch the same
Monteria as this rain gets down into
that area
thank you Jeff so view hurt you know
we've been getting hit hard in the
huffman Kingwood crosby area our
neighboring counties as well suffering a
lot from the rain and we've sent
assistance to Chambers County now we're
seeing this moving slowly south south
west which means an impact to to the
BIOS Jeff mentioned and in the creeks
Greene's halls possibly hunting which
we're watching very closely we have
assets pre deployed ready to respond
we're responding to calls as they come
in we'll be assessing depending on the
calls whether there's a need for
shelters we're in touch with our
nonprofit partners getting ready for any
possible recovery that might be
necessary right now it's about life
safety and so I want to remind folks
you've got dozens of incredibly
experienced dedicated people that have
been here for days and will continue to
be here until we're done with this
incident and they are trained they are
coordinating they are ready to do their
absolute best and when we need from
folks in the community is to help us by
doing your part which means staying home
those under passes that is where people
drown is is when they try driving in
these kinds of conditions so please
don't be in your car go home stay home
and stay attuned to the news if you feel
your life is in danger call 911